the Duggar family is about to get even  bigger  Joanna Duggar and her husband Austin  forsik announced they are expecting  their first child just three months  after tying the knot on Wednesday the  counting on couple shared the exciting  baby news in a sweet video when we found  out we were pregnant we were both  extremely happy and blessed before we  even were married we were praying that  God would give us kids that he has the  proud parents to be have an early  prediction for the sex of their upcoming  bundle of joy there's kind of been a  trend of having boys in the family I  think we're gonna break it have a girl  thank you boy as if that wasn't cute  enough joy and Austin can't stop gushing  about stepping into Parenthood I'm  really looking forward to seeing what  the baby looks like I'm looking forward  to have them in our lives and take them  to places we go and let them experience  life  [Music]